depuis 13 ans il existe une équipe en
defence au sein du club de handball de
montigny les endiablé le club possède
ses propres fauteuil dont tout le monde
dispose une équipe
composée à la fois 2e en 10 et de
valides d'accord donc c'est important
dans le jeu c'est con et mélanger
ensemble s'est parlé on dit d'un côté ce
ne sont pas les valides de l'autre
sur le terrain tout le monde est en
fauteuil j'aimais bien l'idée de la
du mélange de la mixité c'est à dire
hommes femmes toutes tranches d'âge
handicap et valides la direction pour
nous est plus compliqué que pour eux ils
vont à 2000 à l'heure où des formes
l'impression que c'est des tempêtes qui
passent et nous on pousse on pousse en
pousse au total c'est une quinzaine de
personnes qui s'entraînent régulièrement
une discipline de plus en plus connue
qui n'est pourtant pas encore porté aux
jeux paralympiques le malheureusement le
handball n'est pas sport paralympique
contrairement contrairement au basket ou
au rugby on a vu prendre le sport
prendre une place beaucoup plus
importante au fur et à mesure des années
les pratiques sont de plus en plus
diversifiée il ya maintenant possibilité
de faire du handi en escrime en tir à
l'arc en tennis de table
enfin dans plein plein plein de
disciplines une occasion malgré tout de
dépasser le handicap est de montrer que
sur le terrain il n'y a aucune
différence que ya une vie après le
handicap et il s'amuse comme nous ils
sont intégrés comme nous voilà donc je
pense que c'est une vraie vraie réussite
et un vrai moment de décompression comme
nous je pense que quand on joue tous
ensemble dans l'équipe on sait pas qui
est qui handicapée qui est valide c'est
juste une équipe de hand qui joue qui
jouent ensemble qui partagent un bon
moment ensemble avantage durant deux
fauteuils c'est que tout le monde peut
participer qu'on soit valide ou non
valide tout le monde joue en fauteuil et
ça équilibre tout le 10e tournoi
national de hand fauteuil se déroulera
ce samedi 16 octobre au centre sportif
pierre de coubertin
[Musique]